yo o'dell all the salary of bitcoin
hotel did 100 percent with cash app
teamed up said i'm taking 100 of my rams
deal in bitcoin yeah so he's getting a
base salary of 750 000 a 500 000 signing
bonus so call that 1.25 million with
another three million available in
incentives so it could be anywhere from
one point two five one and a quarter
million uh it's over four million
dollars that he's taken in bitcoin which
is pretty crazy what do you think i
don't know how is cash up doing these
deals because it seems like aaron
rodgers did a deal with they gave a
million dollars and then obviously odell
has done a similar deal where he's
giving away a million dollars worth of
bitcoin how does that work uh well
there's a couple different varieties
obviously there's some kind of cash
partnership portion of it that they're
doing right they're affiliated with cash
app and then there's services like uh
like zaps product strike which is what
russell also used last year uh and what
saquon barkley is using this year for
literally it's just tr you're basically
doing a direct deposit for bitcoin right
so an organization pays you
unfortunately the nfl does not allow
people to literally get paid in bitcoin
the team cannot buy bitcoin and give it
to you uh they have to pay you either in
uh via direct deposit or physical check
so what happens is they send a direct
deposit to their this account it gets
converted to bitcoin or exchange for
bitcoin and it's put in there in their
wallet uh before they ever see the money
right so technically he's being being
paid in bitcoin um
but it's wild to see
these companies still doing it right
like i think it makes sense from some
perspective you got to think about it
that like some of these athletes are
going to make hundreds of millions of
dollars right so uh allocating 5 million
or 10 million or something like that in
the grand scheme probably won't be
uh that big of a deal right like it's
just some exposure to the industry and
maybe he's doing more than that i know
he owns a crypto punk and some other
stuff too uh but it's super interesting
just to see this continue to spread
throughout culture right like cash app
has done that more than anyone
partnering with people and giving away
bitcoin uh and continuing to go
and give uh
and get adoption right just just more
ingraining and deeper within culture i
think is important do we think that
odell there's a smart financial decision
for odell to take uh a hundred percent
of the salary in bitcoin yes
i think it's super smart and also i'm
willing to bet that not only does he uh
come out on top from just taking it in
bitcoin rather than dollars but also
from like a cultural standpoint making
himself relevant uh driving other
sponsorship deals etc it'll lead to more
money over time uh which you know and he
also got paid probably by cash app to do
this uh so he's just gonna make more and
more money so i tend to think that not
only is good decision you know on the
bitcoin but also it's gonna be a good
decision for him uh from a business
standpoint as well right
yeah i mean somewhere between one to
four million dollars is what he'll end
up depending on how the incentives play
out from from uh taking cash in bitcoin
and when you think about that cash app
obviously paid him something you know
that he
he owns a crypto punk he's been very
vocal about his uh involvement within
the space so there's obviously going to
be other business ventures or other
partnership deals or things that come
out of this so i think even just from a
cash perspective he probably comes out
on top uh and then from like a a bitcoin
appreciation standpoint obviously we're
big believers that he'll come out on top
there also so i think yeah just from uh
from actual cash he's getting paid the
bitcoin appreciation his relevance and
culture all this it makes a lot of sense
to uh to make a big announcement like
this